if someone came to you and said Alexis
how do I become self-aware what would
you advise him oh-ho-ho well well well
yes I would say to them have your well I
couldn't really tell them what I would
have to say to them I could tell them
what what they could do is have your
major emotional and personal crisis in
your early 20s and then find a way of
dealing with it and then maintain that
way of dealing with it for the rest of
your life no matter how much how great
you think you become how sorted you
think you become just keep on whatever
it was that enabled you to pull yourself
out of that hole just keep on doing it
because the right spiritual principles
practice continuously I found they can
deal with with all the stuff that comes
up everything I've talked about about
dealing with personal issues in the
professional world I've learned about it
because I've gone into the professional
world and I made a mistake I've had a an
interaction with somewhere I've got it
wrong I've upset someone i damaged
something and I've gone home and I've
looked at it in the light of my
spiritual principles or whatever and the
things that i use and and I've tried and
I've got a little more self-awareness
you know and that happens and I make the
mistake again and I go back and I look
at it I try and be honest with myself
about it and I get a little more
self-awareness and this is the process
that I wish I could take credit for it
but it's someone else's spiritual
principles that only happen because I
just utterly failed early in college too
I just had a bad experience in college
so i had to find a new way of living
life and it just happens to have been
continuously applicable for many years
you